[Music]
oh hello I didn't see you there my name
is Caleb dead me and this is game review
today we're gonna be taking a look at a
game between a Toph Anderson and Jean
Dufresne this game is of course the
evergreen game known as such because it
will never die even if it should this
was played in the 1850s and it was a
very tactical game so why don't we just
jump into it here started with e4 e5
Knight f3 knight c6 and Bishop c4 the
Italian Bishop c5 by black and now
instead of the normal joke Oh piano a
quiet maneuvering game we see white go
for the move b4 and this odd-looking
move gives up a pawn but in return white
gains some Tempe in the center here by
gaining time attacking this Bishop on b4
the bishop has to move yet again and now
white can expand in the center with d4
now you might be thinking to yourself
well this pawn is pinned why can't black
just take it black was wondering the
same thing and captured on d4 white went
ahead and castled now this is being
threatened these days black players tend
to take it a bit more conservatively and
they just develop their pieces here just
get developed get castled get safe and
that's the way to go against this
opening instead though Dufresne was a
bit more ambitious in this game played
this move d3 aiming to keep this pawn
stuck on the c3 square white does not
recapture this pawn this pawn is
worthless to him instead Queen b3 is
played and already white is creating
some threats against this black King
Queen f6 is black's choice defending the
f7 square but now e 5 once again puts
the question to this Queen how can you
defend f7 and also not get captured
black cannot take this pawn so I will
simply recapture and things like Bishop
takes f7 wil will come through and
actually even stronger is simply rook e1
here
pinning this Knight to the king and
after move like d6 everything is going
to fall apart
so instead of ticks we see queen g6 now
white plays the move rook e1 supporting
some potential breaks keeping an eye on
these two squares making it difficult
for black to move either of these pawns
black continues with night g e7 and now
white develops this bishop not to any of
these squares but to Bishop a3 trying to
keep an eye on this diagonal trying to
make it tough on black to get Castle for
example if you try to castle here you're
going to run into moves like rook III
just trying to keep pressure up on the
Kings side although perhaps this is what
black should have done just get castled
get your King safe instead though black
plays this weird-lookin move b5 perhaps
trying to take a page out of White's
book here of course white playing b4 in
the opening but in this case it makes a
lot less sense white simply captures
this pawn black does gain time with this
rook by playing rook b8 now after Queen
I 4 and Bishop e6 none of the black
pieces are really coordinated working
together yes
Black has brought this rook to an open
file but it's not really doing anything
it's not working with the rest of
black's pieces and the black king is of
course still stuck in the center white
can completes development with Knight BD
- black plays Bishop d7 now after Knight
e4 some very nasty threats are beginning
to come up are beginning to come up
against this black King black chooses
Queen f5 which is not going to get the
job done simply Bishop takes d3 puts
some threats to this black Queen 96
Knight f6 are both threatened
threatening to win the Queen Queen h5 is
black's choice and now white plays a bit
of a mistake here it's best to just play
simply something like Knight g3
something like rook d1 something like
even work b1
instead though white goes for the throat
plays Knight f6 check when after it
takes takes the King becomes totally
exposed the rook on e 1 is revealed
unfortunately it's not quite as good
with the advent of modern chess and
computers and this game has been
analyzed to death and it turns out Black
has probably
surviving here especially after the game
continuation why it simply brings his
last piece into the game with Europe d1
but now black has a chance to force a
draw here of course in the game black
plays Queen takes f3 this is not enough
to hold the draw he needed to play clean
h3 the reason being he needed to guard
this d7 pawn now checkmate is threatened
white would have to guard against it now
after Queen f5 Bishop d3 is the best
white can do with the repetition well
I'm sorry
Bishop d3 what happens if Queen takes f3
sorry Dani we're taking a break here ok
stockfish was just confused I understand
now alright jumping back into it and
after Queen f5 Bishop d3 is the best
white can do with a draw black can
repeat with Queen h3 and there's nothing
to be done if you try to do anything
else
something like king h1 for example
breaking out of the pen black it's
simply gonna take this pawn and wreath
and find some safety for himself in the
game though of course black did not find
Queen h3 and instead took this knight on
f3 a natural mistake like is still
threatening checkmate but this gives
white the opportunity he needed to crush
the black king of course it starts with
rook take c7 Knight takes c7 then if you
haven't seen this game before I
encourage you to try and find the only
winning continuation here hopefully you
can do it it's a fun one go ahead and
pause the video alright here it is it's
of course Queen takes d7 check
sacrificing the Queen and allowing white
to play Bishop f5 check guarding all of
the squares from the black King King c6
does not get the job done
Bishop d7 is mate of course King e8
which was played in the game is met with
Bishop d7 check went after King f8 or d8
Bishop takes e7 is simply checkmate and
this is how the game actually ended so
this game is a real beauty the evergreen
game because it will never die a
course some mistakes by both players but
that's to be expected from a game so
early on in chess is history and from
such a a tactical game as well hopefully
you enjoyed it thank you very much for
joining me on this episode of my name is
Caleb Denby and I will see you next time